>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> John Fenn: Welcome to
the Whittall Pavilion.
My name is John Fenn.
I'm the head of research
and programs
at the American Folk Life
Center, the Library of Congress,
and I'd like to welcome you
to the latest presentation
in our ongoing Benjamin
A. Botkin lecture series.
The Botkin series allows
us to highlight the work
of leading scholars in the
disciplines of folklore,
ethnomusicology, oral history,
and cultural heritage while
enhancing the collections here
at the American Folk Life Center
and the Library of Congress.
For the center and
for the library,
the Botkin lectures
form an important facet
of our acquisition activities.
Each lecture is video-recorded
and becomes part
of the permanent
collections of the library.
In addition, the Botkin lectures
are later posted as webcasts
on the library's website, where
they are available for viewing
to internet patrons throughout
the world, and reminder here:
If you haven't already done so,
please turn off your cell phone
or put it on airplane mode.
It tends to interfere with
the sound in the lectern.
Although the AFC is one of the
smaller divisions of the Library
of Congress, the
size and breadth
of the center's archival
holdings are extensive.
In fact, all on its own, the
AFC is the world's largest
ethnographic archive.
It contains over 3,000 field
work collections and boasts more
than 5 million items
documenting hundreds
of traditional cultures
throughout the world.
Our holdings include
documentation on music, dance,
narrative tales, oral
history, and all other aspects
of traditional knowledge
and cultural expressions.
Our public programming
activities are equally
as broad-based.
Last week, we presented a
Botkin speaker on Syriac chants
in Aramaic Christianity.
Next well, we'll
host a talk on Cajun
and Creole culture in Louisiana.
And today, we are
especially delighted
to present a Botkin lecture
by our esteemed friend
and colleague Andrea Graham,
who is a prominent expert
on the folklore, folk life,
and traditional culture
of the American West.
Andrea has worked as a public
folklorist for over 35 years,
and 30 of those have been spent
in the inter-mountain West.
Currently the folk
life specialist
at the American Studies
Department of the University
of Wyoming, Andrea
received undergraduate
and graduate training at the
University of Pennsylvania.
Although originally
from the east coast,
she has spent the majority
of her career documenting
the inter-mountain West.
Before moving to
Laramie in 2009,
she worked as a public
sector folklorist
and undertook field work
and programming projects
in California, Idaho,
Iowa, Montana,
Nevada, Utah, and Wyoming.
From 1990, to 2000, she served
as the folk life
program coordinator
for the Nevada Arts Council
and has also worked for state
and regional folk arts
programs in Virginia,
Tennessee, and Florida.
Now working as a folklorist,
educator, and researcher
at the Wyoming -- at the
University of Wyoming
in Laramie, which is located
on the very exotic-sounding
high Laramie Plains,
Andrea is widely admired
throughout the field
for the breadth, creativity,
and excellence of her research,
scholarship, and programming.
Today, Andrea will be speaking
about her recent field work
project for Art of the Hunt,
which explored and documented
hunting and fishing lore
and related traditions
in contemporary America.
The project highlighted
the many crafts, skills,
occupational traditions,
and narrative stories
that are an important part of
Wyoming's rich hunting culture
and continue to shape Wyoming's
sense of cultural identity
and regional uniqueness.
The Art of the Hunt,
which culminated in 2014
with a year-long exhibit at
the Wyoming State Museum,
was a landmark event, and we
are dedicated to welcoming --
we are delighted to welcoming
Andrea to the Library
of Congress to talk about her
research and her findings.
Please join me in welcoming her.
[ Applause ]
>> Andrea Graham: All right.
It's a treat to be here and see
some of my friends out there
and some Wyoming folks.
I talked to several
Wyoming folks.
Anyone else from Wyoming
or lived in Wyoming?
Okay. It's a small contingent.
So how many of you are
hunters or have ever hunted?
We got a few.
Okay. Or fished?
A lot more people have fished.
Okay. It's much easier or less
gear-intensive to go fishing.
In Wyoming, in a room like
this, probably at least half
of the people would
put their hands up
and say they were hunters,
maybe three quarters.
In some towns, it
would be everybody.
It's an enormous part of
the culture in Wyoming.
It's a big state, lots
of wide-open spaces,
lots of public land.
About 50% of the land is public,
and with a more recent history
of non-native settlement.
Laramie, where I live,
is celebrating its 150th
anniversary this year,
so that's pretty recent
compared to the east coast.
So all over Wyoming, you
will see things like this,
collections of photos.
Let me get that arrow
out of there.
People's hunting photos
that they will post,
and this is a little store
in a town called Aladdin.
You'll see them in
cafes, in motels.
The tire shop where
I got my tire changed
in Laramie has a whole
wall of hunting photos.
It's just what people do
and what they show off
to their community.
I myself am not from a hunting
background or hunting family.
As John said, I'm originally
from the east coast.
We weren't hunters.
It just wasn't part
of my environment.
So the first I really
remember being aware
of how important hunting was --
my first job out of grad school
was in rural southwest Virginia,
and I learned that schools
were closed on the first day
of hunting season in the fall
because half the kids
wouldn't have shown up.
They were -- that
was more important.
That didn't happen in suburban
Philadelphia, but it does happen
in Rock Springs, Wyoming.
I saw this sign in the
cable company stores.
Like, "We're going hunting.
We don't care.
It's more important
than your business."
[Laughter] So that's the nature
of how important hunting
is in these communities.
So I was a total
outsider to this world
of hunting and fishing.
I fished a little
bit, but never hunted.
Not really interested
in hunting myself.
I don't mind if other
people do it.
So there's advantages and
disadvantages to being that much
of an outsider when
you're doing field work.
You can kind of go in and
say, "I don't know anything,"
and you'll get a
lot of really --
you can ask really
dumb questions
and sometimes get really
good answers that someone
who did know the culture maybe
wouldn't even think to ask,
so that can be an advantage.
You know, when I think the fact
-- and I was very up-front.
I said, "I know nothing
about this.
Explain it to me," and the fact
that it was a woman
I think also helped.
People didn't expect me to
know anything about hunting,
although there are a
lot of women hunters,
and there's an increasing
number of women hunters,
but people were very polite
and answered my questions,
and who knows what
they said after I left.
Like, "Who was that?"
[Laughter] So a little bit
of background on Wyoming,
for those of you who don't know.
It's one of those big,
square states out west.
It's the tenth largest
state in size.
It is the least populous state.
There are fewer than
600,000 people.
That's fewer than live in DC,
and that number's
actually dropping
because there's a big bust
in the energy industry,
and people are leaving.
It's the second least densely
populated after Alaska.
So there's tons of open space.
Original inhabitants in the
north were the Crow Indians
on the Montana border, the
Lakota into South Dakota,
but their territory
included eastern Wyoming,
and then the eastern Shoshone
and the northern Arapaho
were tribes there,
so I think you can
see kind of in the --
just west of center is the
Wind River Reservation.
That's Shoshone and
Arapaho territory today.
Grand Teton National -- or
Yellowstone National Park is
in the far northwest corner.
Grand Teton is just south of
it and the town of Jackson.
The capital is Cheyenne, which
is in the opposite, southeast,
corner, almost into Colorado.
Laramie is 50 miles
west of that.
That's where I live,
at the university.
It's the only four-year
university in the state.
Then Casper used to
be the biggest town.
It was a big oil town.
In the center of the
state, you can kind
of see the Rocky Mountains run
diagonally through the state.
In the north central part,
the Bighorn Mountains.
The area between there
and Yellowstone is
called the Bighorn Basin,
where the town of Cody is.
I did a bunch of
field work there,
so I'll be referring
to the Bighorn Basin.
Green River and Rock
Springs are in the southeast.
So those are sort of some
of the key locations,
and I'm just going to
sort of take you along
on my field work travels, which
started in the northeast corner
in Crook County,
the town of Hulett,
which is the closest
town to Devil's Tower.
It's up in that corner.
So I was hired in 2007 by
the Wyoming Arts Council
to do just a field work
survey in that county,
and I have to credit Annie
Hatch, who was the folklorist
with the Wyoming Arts Council.
This project really is her idea.
She came up with it, and she and
I worked very closely together.
This whole project
was a joint project
between the arts council
and the university.
So I wish she could
be here, too.
It's definitely her baby.
So she just hired me to do
just a field survey up there,
so I was driving down
Hulett's main street,
the one-block main street,
and saw a little building
with a sign that said
Deer Creek Taxidermy.
So well, that would
be interesting.
That sounds kind of folk.
So I walked in and saw these
sort of ghostly animal forms.
These are called mannequins.
They're the foundation
for taxidermy
that you put the skin over.
They come in all different kinds
of animals and shapes and sizes,
but it was kind of a spooky
thing to walk in and see these,
and then I met J. R. Butler,
who was the proprietor,
the taxidermist, and I
was introducing myself,
and when I -- as soon as I said
I was from the arts council,
he just lit up, like oh.
Usually, when I'm doing
field work and I say I'm
with an arts organization,
if I'm maybe in a quilt shop,
asking about quilters, if I
say I'm from an arts council,
they immediately
try and send you
to the painter up the street.
Like, "Well, that's the artist."
They don't think of themselves
as artists, and you have
to convince them that no,
I really am interested
in your quilt.
But J. R. said, "Oh, I'm so
glad the Arts Council recognizes
taxidermy is an art form.
It's creative.
You want to bring
the animals to life."
He was just all over that.
So he was thrilled to be
interviewed by the Arts Council.
So he likes to -- you know,
the poses of an animal, this --
what's called habitat that
he really likes to use,
these pieces of wood
and rocks and plants
to make a setting
for the animal.
All of that is creative to him.
So he was a great person to
interview, and he's been --
he has three sons, and he's
been teaching his kids.
This is one of his kids,
Austin, who was in the shop.
He's now in high school
or college, probably,
but he was totally
into taxidermy.
He would help his
dad with the skins.
He had done some small
pieces and won awards.
He was like a spokesman
for this shop,
and he knew all the terminology,
and he was just a blast,
so I had to get this picture
of him with the horns.
So it looks like this
tradition is going to be passed
on in the family,
which is great.
So J. R. does a lot of work
for out-of-state hunters,
and out-of-state hunters are
an enormous economic impact
in the state.
There are a lot of them.
They spend a lot of money.
They have to pay extra
for hunting licenses,
for out-of-state
hunting licenses.
They have to hire
guides and outfitters.
In certain areas,
they're required.
They stay in motels.
They eat food.
They pay taxidermists
to do their taxidermy.
So it's a huge economic impact,
and so they will leave
their trophy with J. R.,
and the food -- there's a
program, I think through Game
and Fish, where they can
donate the meat to food banks,
because wasting meat
is a big no-no.
I mean if somebody goes
out and kills an animal
and just takes the head
and leaves the meat,
Game and Fish will
track them down.
They're not -- that's wasting.
You're not supposed to do that.
So anyway, just from this
first visit with J. R.,
when I wasn't even looking for
hunting stuff, I learned a lot
about the importance of
family hunting traditions.
He hunts with his kids.
They hunt with their
grandparents.
A deep understanding of animals
and their environment is
required to be a hunter
as well as a taxidermist.
You have to think like the
animal to be able to know
where they're going to go
and what they're going to do,
and then the economic --
I mean the cultural as well
as the economic importance
of hunting.
So just from this one visit,
I learned all kinds of stuff.
Two years later, I was hired
again by the Arts Council --
and I was still living
in Idaho --
to do a survey in that
Bighorn Basin that I mentioned,
the area around Cody, and
this time, it really --
it was specifically looking
for hunting traditions,
because Annie had pulled
together a committee
of folklorists, and they wanted
to come up with a project
that they could do, a statewide
research project, and they came
up with hunting as a topic,
largely from John Dorst,
who's a folklorist who has
taught at the university
for over 30 years and has
been doing a lot of research
on taxidermy, about
people's images of animals,
animals in art, of
course hunting.
So they kind of jointly
came up with this idea
of hunting traditions.
It's obvious.
It's everywhere in the state.
So that's how this
project came about.
They wanted to look at the
craft associated with hunting,
the gear that people make,
but also the cultural knowledge
that's required to participate
in this, and they sort
of narrowed their focus
to really big game
hunting and fishing,
and there are all
kinds of other hunting.
There are birds and wild fowl,
and there's hunting with dogs
and hunting of predators, which
is a hot-button issue right now,
and just do not have the time to
do that, so the focus really was
on big game and fishing,
and hunting brings up a lot
of issues about the wild,
the domestic, humans going
into the wild, the
idea of fair chase,
that hunting is an
equal competition,
that the animals have a chance.
It's there's no guarantee,
and that, you know, the rules,
the hunting rules, make sure
that it's an even match.
So humans may have these fancy
rifles with, you know, sights,
and they can shoot
for hundreds of yards,
but you have to be on foot.
You can't chase animals on ATVs.
You can't.
The new rule is you can't
use a drone to go scouting
where the animals are.
They have to put in new rules
to account for new technology,
so those restrictions -- you
can't shoot from your vehicle,
you can't shoot from the road
-- to make it fair chase,
that it's an even match
between humans and animals.
So that's the concept
of hunting.
If you go to an elk farm
and just shoot an elk
that's standing there,
that's not hunting.
There's no -- you know,
there's no challenge.
So okay. So the other thing that
hunters are very aware of is
that they are taking a
life to benefit their life,
and it's part -- it's been
part of human culture forever.
Humans are carnivores.
But I found this.
I still see hunting
stuff all the time.
I'm just tuned into it now.
But there was an article in
The New York Times Magazine
with a quote that really
summarizes how most
hunters feel.
He says, "There is a sadness
that only hunters know,
a moment when lament overshadows
any desire for celebration.
Life is sustained by
death, and though going
to the field is an act of
taking responsibility for that,
the killing is not
easy, nor should it be,"
and most hunters
understand that,
certainly in Native
American tradition,
the idea of an animal giving
itself to support people.
So that's a big concept.
So I went to Cody to
do this field work.
Annie had given me some leads,
and there's a folklorist
named Mary Ann Andreas who,
at the time, was working at the
Buffalo Bill Center of the West,
which is in Cody,
fabulous museum in Cody,
and she had told me
about this business,
this Wyoming Outdoor Outfitters,
that had just closed,
unfortunately, but
their sign was still up,
this horse really packed,
with panniers and a diamond --
double diamond hitch in the
harness, and he's ready to go
out packing and hunting.
So I thought this boded well for
my field work that this was here
on the skyline of Cody.
So a couple of the artists
that I found up there.
A man named Rich Wormington,
who makes bows, wooden longbows
and recurve bows, which are
traditional hunting bows.
Just made them in his
garage in his spare time.
He didn't want it
to be a business,
although he did have a website,
and most bowhunters will start
out using these fancy new
compound bows that are made
of high-tech materials, and
they have gears and pulleys
and sights, and it
makes it easier.
You don't have to be as strong.
They can shoot further.
And Rich was sort of very
careful not to say anything
against those kind of bows,
because that's how people
get started in bowhunting,
and the bowhunting
community is much smaller
than the gun hunting community,
so he felt like they had
to stick together, but he feels
like hunting with these kind
of bows is real hunting.
It takes much more
skill, more strength.
You have to be closer to an
animal, so you have to be better
at tracking to use them,
and some people who start
with compound bows eventually
want to learn these kind
of bows, because it's
more of a challenge.
So he makes -- I
asked him how to --
just walk me through
the process,
how do you make these bows,
because I was clueless.
So he has different
kinds of wood
that have different properties.
Some are more flexible.
Some are stronger.
He combines them.
He laminates them to get the
right qualities that he wants,
and then he heats them
so they're flexible
and then puts them in these
molds that he's designed
to put them in shape of the bow,
and then once they're taken out,
they have to be sanded and
finished and tested and gotten
to the right strength.
I don't understand bow --
they have to do with pounds
and length, like how
many pounds it takes
to pull it back, two
feet to shoot it.
Anyway, so he has
all these equipment
that he can get the bows
to exactly the quality
that he wants, and
they're just beautiful.
The first one that he was
holding had snake skin
on it for decoration.
Okay. Then I was referred to --
actually, I was talking
to Mary Ann
and a colleague at the museum.
And her colleague said, "That
guy who goes to our church
who makes those camp stoves."
I said, "Camp stoves?"
I never would have
thought to ask about that.
I didn't know people actually
made camp stoves, but this guy,
Brian Robertson, lives outside
of Cody and was a farmer
and then started repairing farm
machinery to make more money
and so knew how to work with
metal, and he was a hunter
and liked to go back
and set up hunting camp.
So he designed this little camp
stove that you can pack up,
pack on a horse, pack
into hunting camp.
So now he sells them
as a business.
He also makes bear-proof
food storage containers
and trash cans that are
used in campgrounds,
Forest Service campgrounds,
and they have
to be certified bear-proof.
So how do you certify
that's something bear-proof?
You throw it to the bears
and have them test it.
So they take it to -- there's a
bear and wolf discovery center
in west Yellowstone, so if
he designs a new food storage
thing, they take it, and I
think they put smelly food in it
and throw it in with the
bears and let them jump on it
and pound on it, and if
they can't break into it
in a set amount of time,
it's certified as bear proof.
I just thought that was great.
So he has a business.
He sells these, you know,
to the Forest Service.
If he changes his design,
they have to be retested,
so he doesn't change
the design very often.
He also designed this
cool little camp kitchen
that packs in.
It's two panniers that you pack
in on a horse, and you pull
out the legs and the top,
and you have this nice little
kitchen to set up in your camp,
and he told us -- he said, "It's
not necessary to go to the hills
and be uncomfortable."
[Laughter] He goes camping.
He has his tent.
He has his cots.
He has his stoves.
He has his nice little
kitchen, you know.
So then he sells these
as a side business.
Then we heard about this guy
named Von Ringler who's a
leather worker.
Used to -- he learned,
originally,
from a kit that his wife got
him and then really got into it,
and there are a lot of
leather workers in Cody.
So he learned from them, and
he used to have a storefront,
and he said there was too much
wasted time, people coming in
and taking him away from
his work, so now he lives
about 30 miles north in a
little place called Clark
and has his own shop, and
he specializes in holsters
and gun-related, like cartridge
belts and rifle scabbards,
and you'd think that would be a
pretty specialized thing to do
in leather work, but he
makes a living at it.
He actually has a couple
people who work for him.
He has a website.
He'll do custom orders.
People have special guns.
He has a whole collection
of wooden dummy guns
of different kinds
that he can use
as models for these holsters.
He invented something he calls
the Wyoming combination holster.
You can wear it either over
your shoulder or on your hip,
depending on what you're doing.
He sold a thousand of
these, over a thousand,
because he had his number
1,000 that he had numbered.
And so I asked him, you know,
"Where do you sell these?
Do you sell them around town?"
He said, "Oh, yeah, there's a,
you know, outdoor store in Cody
that has a bunch of stuff," and
I said, "I was in that store
and asked the clerk, you know,
do you have any locally
made gear, and he goes, 'No,
I don't think so,'
and Von just laughed.
He says, "I have a whole wall of
stuff in there," you know sort
of standard holsters
and cartridge cases,
and I think he had some
cell phone holsters.
So I started around the store,
trying to find some
more local stuff,
since the clerk obviously
didn't know,
and came across these
ice fishing jigs,
which is something else I
wouldn't have thought about,
but ice fishing is very
popular in Wyoming.
We have lots of winter,
and people don't want
to stop fishing in the
winter, so they ice fish.
So this was a local couple
that just had this
business making jigs,
and they're based on lead.
They had molds where
they did the --
formed the lead pieces
that are sort of the base,
because you need the -- it
needs to sit down there,
under the ice, and then they
decorate them with deer hair
and fluorescent colors.
And so we, Annie and
I, went back later
and interviewed this --
these guys that made
these ice fishing jigs.
Then I was down in Thermopolis,
which is in the southern part
of Bighorn Basin, and
walked into this farm
and ranch supply store and
saw these pack saddles,
which are pretty
snazzy for pack saddles.
Usually, they're pretty basic.
They're just the bars
that go on the horse
and the things at the top.
Especially the one on the
left that's all leather.
So I found the store owner
and said, "Who made those?"
and he gave me the name of
the people who had made them,
but then he also said -- he
said, "My wife, Cindy Denton,
does leather work, too.
She's in the back of the
store doing some stuff.
Do you want to go see her?"
"Yes, of course I do."
So I went back there, and
she just does small projects,
things like belts and chaps,
and she was working on --
these are saddle pockets.
They go on the back of a saddle
to just carry your little gear
in when you're hunting
or whatever,
and of course it
has an elk on it.
So these are used for hunting.
So that was fun, to see her
very small-scale leather work,
and then I went down to
see Tex and Dale Frasier,
who make those pack saddles
in this little, tiny shop.
Tex grew up -- his family was
outfitters outside of Jackson,
so he grew up packing and
understood how pack saddles work
and had made some improvements,
where the buckles --
he moved the buckles so
they weren't under the load,
so if you had adjust, you didn't
have to unpack your whole load.
Things like that.
So he was making saddles, and
they did lots of repair work
on old saddles and leather
goods in this eensy shop,
and Dale makes panniers out of
nylon and that kind of stuff.
So here's a couple.
There is usually what
pack saddles look like.
He said the fancy leather one he
had made for the Forest Service
or someone with the
Forest Service,
but these are the two
basic kind of pack saddles.
The lower one is the crossbuck,
which is sort of the standard,
just two crosspieces of wood
that you can hang stuff off of.
Sorry. I keep hitting this.
And the other one is
called a decker saddle,
and those aluminum
parts are manufactured,
so you have to buy them and
then put them on the bar.
Some people prefer one or the
other for the way they pack.
So that was my adventures
in the Bighorn Basin.
I found lots more people
who make hunting gear,
talked to another
pack saddle maker,
a couple of leather workers,
saddle makers, some outfitters.
There's lot of that
activity in that area.
And then that fall, fall of
2009, is when I started working
at the university,
mainly as a researcher.
Do a little bit of teaching,
but I knew that this Art
of the Hunt was going to be my
project for the next five years.
So early on, Annie
had a teenage son
who had taken the hunter safety
course, and she took it with him
as research, and she
suggested that I do that, too,
and it was really
interesting to take this.
It's a free course that Fish
and Game offers that everyone
who gets a hunting license
has to take this course
so they know the regulations
and how to safely carry a gun,
especially when you're
in a group of people.
Don't shoot toward something
where you don't know what's
behind it, the laws about --
you know, you can't
shoot from a vehicle.
You can't shoot from a road,
and they really emphasized sort
of upholding the image of
hunters as conscientious
and safe and not
these wild, crazy,
drunk people shooting off guns.
They really want to promote
hunting as a family sport,
as a way to get outside,
you know,
as a part of Wyoming's
way of life.
They really emphasize that.
So I passed the course
and got this little badge,
and here is a guy talking about
a hunt and sort of what it means
to do a good, ethical hunt.
Whoops.
>> Last fall, I had an animal
hunt, just between Shoshone
and Casper with my son and
my wife, and we went down,
and we split up, and I went with
my son, and I think, you know,
something that you could be
proud of is this ethical,
those successful hunts, but
where you did everything right.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, we'd been out
sighting in the right formation,
and with each new bird he shot,
making sure we were prepared
and had our licenses.
>> Yeah.
>> And we had our
hunter safety cards.
We had our hunter orange so
that we were visible and safe,
you know, and we went down
and we glassed the antelope,
and we used the binoculars
to view and try and figure
out which one we wanted to go
after, and we made a choice,
and we started stalking
him, and actually,
we bumped into a couple
different groups of antelope,
and which we got a little
sidetracked on, but my son said,
'No, I really want to
go for that one we saw,"
and we laid in wait for him.
He was out too far, and we
laid there, and we talked,
and finally, they started
moving our way, and they --
and moved up, and then in
one shot, he had it down.
You know, he had a split-second
opportunity to make the shot,
and he was prepared,
and he did it.
>> Yeah.
>> And it went right
down, and it was clean.
It was ethical, --
>> Yeah.
>> -- and tasty at the
end of the day [laughter].
It was really, really good, and
actually, we don't have a lot
of mounted wildlife in this
house, but we have his antelope.
>> Yeah.
>> On the way out, he can look
up on the wall and see it,
and it's the memory
of that hunt, --
>> Yeah.
>> -- that it was clean.
>> It was the way it
was supposed to be done.
You can do it, and that's what
makes it even sweeter than,
you know, rolling down
the window on the highway
and shooting a great, big buck.
That might go into the book.
It might be some kind of record.
>> Right.
>> But that's not
much of a memory.
>> Yeah.
>> And it's not --
that's not a fair chase.
>> Yeah.
>> Andrea Graham: So that really
encapsulates what the state is
trying to promote and
what the vast majority
of hunters -- how they hunt.
This guy was a singer,
and we had sent one
of our grad students
out to interview several
singer-songwriters
if they had written songs
about hunting or fishing.
So the student took along
another student, Peter Gibbons,
to take photographs,
and Peter -- we came --
he came back with
these wonderful photos,
and we realized that Peter
was a fabulous photographer.
So we later recruited
him the next summer,
gave him an internship with
the Arts Council to go out
and take portraits of the
artists that we were going
to include in our exhibit,
and so all of the really
nice pictures you see
in this are his.
They're not mine.
He's -- like this one
portrait he made of Audra
and Mike Draper, who
are knife makers.
Audra studied with a
master knife maker,
and she actually has master
knife maker certification.
It's this whole process,
and she's been teaching
her husband Mike
to make these knives.
So they start with
just plain steel
and forge them down
and make knives.
This is one of hers --
Damascus steel, which is layers
of different kinds of steel
that are hammered together
and re-layered and
layered and layered,
and then when you cut them, they
make these beautiful designs.
They look like topographic maps.
Really beautiful stuff.
So this is one of
Audra's knives.
This is Al Darlington,
who's a fish taxidermist,
which is pretty specialized,
but he has a full-time
business doing this.
He studied art at the university
and sort of fell into a job
with a taxidermist and
eventually took over, but fish,
when they're dead,
they lose their color.
The colors fade, so you
have to repaint them
if you taxiderm [phonetic] them.
So that's his art
background comes in handy,
being a fish taxidermist,
plus he's a great guy.
Charles McCall is
someone from Cheyenne.
Used to work for Fish and Game.
He helped us very early on.
He's hunted all his life and
fished, especially fishing.
He loves fishing.
He makes flies.
He's taught fly tying.
He likes to use natural
materials like feathers
and deer hair, and he took us
out ice fishing,
which was great.
I had never been ice
fishing, and I wanted
to see what it was about, and
we had a videographer with us.
We'd been shooting little
sort of video portraits
of these artists that we had
hoped to use in our exhibit.
We ended up not being able to,
because it was too expensive,
but we have these videos.
So let me see if this will play.
[ Music ]
>> We're in Crystal
Reservoir right now,
and we're getting ready to
unload our gear and go down
and see if we can catch a fish.
I'll grab the auger and
I'll go out about ten feet,
and then I'll drill
a hole and will check
to see how thick the ice is.
[ Auger Sounds ]
This one is called
a deezit [phonetic],
and you put it on your hook.
It has the little tentacles,
too, and they have --
they make them in various
colors, but that really looks
like a fish to me, and
that's what we're going
to try here in a minute.
When we were to Evanston
ice fishing,
I had one of those little
red jigs, red-headed jigs
with the little white
legs on it,
and it was early in the morning.
We were fishing, and my buddy
was in the other ice hut.
>> Oh, yes.
Are you getting this?
[Laughter]
>> And I hooked onto this
big fish and had him hooked,
and I fought him for, oh,
I don't know, maybe --
it seemed like a half-hour,
but it really wasn't.
It was maybe five minutes.
>> Yeah, you got him, Bill.
Let him wear out, because
I think he's a pretty
good-sized one.
>> And when I got him straight
up and down, he just went
like that and knocked
that -- busted my line.
>> Well, we'll see
if we get him out.
>> You could hear some language
coming from that ice hut
for a little while [laughter].
Later on in the day, there
was another guy fishing
over by the dam, and he caught a
big fish and won the tournament.
We happened to know that guy,
and we were talking to him
when he was up getting
his prize.
>> Oh.
>> This is a nice fish.
He really is.
He's a nice one.
He said, "You know, there
was a big fish with this fish
that had a jig in its
mouth," and I said, "Well,
what kind of a jig was that
and what color was it?"
and he said, "Well, it was kind
of a lead head with a red head
on it with the long,
white tentacles on it."
>> Oh!
>> Guess whose fish
that was [laughter].
And once in a while,
this is what happens.
You get lucky.
I would say this fish
probably goes about,
oh, maybe four pounds.
Well, it's been a lot of fun.
Met a lot of nice
people, and we've got
to see a nice, big fish caught.
>> Okay, here he goes.
>> Change the song, then.
>> We've got a family wager
that the first fish is a dollar,
the most fish is another dollar,
and the biggest fish
is another dollar,
so if you catch the
biggest fish right off,
you at least got three
dollars [laughter].
Is that funny?
[ Music ]
>> Andrea Graham: So
that was a lot of fun.
Ice fishing is mostly sitting
and waiting, and it's --
we were really lucky that he
caught that fish on camera,
[laughter] and he has a great
"the one that got away" story,
too, that goes with it.
So here are a couple of other
artists that we worked with.
This is Jim Blair,
who's an engraver.
Works with both gunsmiths
and knife makers
to engrave their pieces.
Just incredible detail.
Beautiful work.
Carla Snook lives
back up in Hulett.
When I was doing
that first project,
I had seen all these
metal signs.
There are lots of -- like ranch
gates will have a metal sign
across the top of people
roping or whatever.
You'll come into a town,
and there will be a sign
for the town that will be
this cut-out metal design,
and I saw lots of them all over
this county, and I kept asking
who made these signs,
because they were really nice,
nicer than the usual
ones, and finally,
the last day I was
there, I found --
somebody told me
it's Carla Snook,
and she's the art
teacher at the school.
So I didn't have time to talk
to her, but I found her mailbox,
so I knew this was the
right person, and we had --
Annie and I had always wanted
one of those entry gates
for this exhibit, so when
-- I went back later,
when we were designing the
exhibit, and we commissioned her
to make the metal part.
So here's one of the pieces,
and you'll see the
full gate later on.
She grew up on this ranch.
She still lives there.
She learned to do these metal
signs just as a sideline
and just does all her own
designs and cuts them by hand,
and some people have
these computerized things
that will print out metal signs,
but hers are all
individually done.
This is John Jones, who
makes bamboo fly rods.
We found a couple of
people who made these.
It's a very meticulous process.
They're made out of
bamboo that only comes
from one particular
region of China.
They're hexagonal, so you
have to make six little splits
and then shape them and put
them together, glue them.
He worked as a machinist in
the coal mines near Gillette,
so he has made a lot
of his own equipment.
This one jig sort of -- once
it's glued, it's wrapped
with string to hold it together
and then put in this oven
and then baked so the glue
sticks, and he made all
of this equipment, and then he
goes out and tests them himself.
He's -- all of these
gear makers are hunters
and fishers and use their gear.
Sticking with fishing,
this is Marvin Nolte,
who makes what are
called salmon flies,
which are really not
a Wyoming tradition,
not at all a Wyoming tradition.
It was from the British Isles.
They used to fish
these big salmon,
I guess ocean-going
salmon, in the rivers,
so they made these big --
this shows you how big.
They're this big, and
they've turned into this sort
of art form and collector's
item.
So he makes these.
He has all kinds of exotic
feathers that he uses
to make these salmon flies that
are just gorgeous, and so we had
to have him in the exhibit.
Even though they're
not used in Wyoming,
they're made in Wyoming.
There are loads of
decorative art
with hunting themes
-- quilts, rugs.
That first opening slide,
that's a hooked wool rug.
Things made out of antlers,
like antler chandeliers.
I've always wanted one.
Cribbage boards that
are made out of antlers.
Carved wooden fish or
wooden animals -- birds.
This is a Native American
beadwork tradition.
This is a Shoshone artist
named Glenda Trosper.
They're like photographs.
The detail in these pieces
is amazing, and she does lots
of pieces with native
animals in them.
Just incredible work.
Here's another fish rug.
This is my fish rug.
I found it in a store
in Aladdin.
There were a couple of
these rugs and chair pads,
and I could tell they were --
someone local had made them,
and I just loved this smiling
fish, so I had to buy it.
So I asked, when I checked
out, "Who made this?"
and they gave me the name
of the woman who made it,
who lived back in the country,
and I ended up going back
and interviewing her, and she
just buys old wool clothes
from thrift shops and
cuts them into strips
and makes these hooked
rugs with, again,
using designs from nature.
That's very common in the state.
So the ultimate goal of
this project had always been
to have an exhibit.
So we had been talking to
the state museum in Cheyenne,
and they were very excited,
but they said, you know,
"We don't have the staff
or the capability to design
and build this exhibit.
You'll have to find
an outside company,
which we had not been expecting,
so we had to push
everything back a year.
We had to raise a
bunch of money.
We did have funding
from the NEA.
Wyoming has a cultural trust
fund which gave us a lot
of support, our humanities
council, both of our agencies,
and we hired a company
called Split Rock Studios
out of Saint Paul, Minnesota,
a very well-known design firm.
We were thrilled to have them.
So we worked with them to design
this exhibit, and we had kind
of planned out a
storyline, Annie and I,
sort of an introduction.
What is folk art?
Then sort of planning
for the hunt, preparing,
making all the gear, being
out in the field, camping,
storytelling, back home
after the hunt, taxidermy,
all the things that are
made with materials,
or decorative items, and then
we added a last section on sort
of conservation efforts.
Hunters will tell you
they're the biggest
conservation supporters.
They are, because they want lots
of open space and
land and animals.
So there are things like there's
a one-shot antelope hunt,
which is sort of a competition
between the governors of Wyoming
and Colorado, but it's all men.
So about five years ago,
the Wyoming Women's Foundation
started a women's antelope hunt,
which has been extremely
successful, very popular,
and get more women
involved in hunting,
and there are more women.
The number of hunters in general
is declining, but the number
of women is increasing.
So we sent the designers
hundreds of photographs
and interview transcripts,
and somehow they pulled all
that information and, you know,
produced all the exhibit
text and the labels.
We told them which artists
we were going to have
and which pieces in general
we were going to have,
and they were wonderful
to work with.
So meanwhile, Annie and I
were picking out objects.
This is a whole bunch
of taxidermy
that the museum insisted
was quarantined
to make sure they didn't
have bugs [laughter].
They didn't want bugs in their
museum, so they were lying
around in the Arts
Council's back office
with [laughter] bug
stickers on them.
And in general, we allowed
artists to send us pieces
that they wanted displayed.
So we might say a particular
-- like we asked Von Ringer,
"We want one of those
Wyoming combination hostlers."
So he sent one that
was very plain.
It didn't have a lot of fancy
tooling, and Annie was sort
of surprised, thought
he might want
to show off his fancier work,
and she asked him why he chose
that, and he said, "Well,
that's what most hunters
would take into the field,
would be a basic,
functional, not a fancy piece,"
which totally makes
sense, you know.
So we let them choose
what they wanted to send,
and J. R. Butler, the
taxidermist, was helping us
with a number of pieces.
He got us an elk, an elk
head, which we really wanted,
and he had sent photos of
a number of pieces for us
to choose from, and
this was one of them.
It's very unusual.
It's an unusual specimen.
The buck has these weird
antlers, and apparently,
the owner had told J. R. just
like do what you want
with it [laughter].
Your face.
So it has this arm with holding
a bow made out of some kind
of material that he uses to
make fake rocks and stuff.
So we were -- it's like, "Well,
this is really interesting
[laughter], and this is --
" John Dorst said this is
really a trend in taxidermy,
to make these art pieces
or to tell a story,
but this was pretty
far-out in the world
of traditional taxidermy,
and the exhibit -- we were --
and we wanted the best stuff.
We wanted excellent quality
stuff, but really sort
of representing the traditions,
and this is pretty far
out on the tradition
scale of things.
So we talked about it.
We were afraid it would be
too distracting from the rest
of the show, that this would end
up being a focus, and went back
and forth about it and, you
know, finally wrote him back
and said, you know, "Here
are the pieces we want,
but I don't think we can really
use that piece on the pedestal
with the arm," [laughter]
and he was very upset.
He really wanted this
piece in the show,
because he considers
himself an artist.
This was something where he
was really artistic and wanted
to show this off, and an artist
wants people to look at his work
and go "wow," and we wanted
people to go "nice taxidermy"
and will not be distracted,
but he convinced us to let --
you know, to include
it in the show,
and he had been so
helpful to us.
So he and his son were --
loaded up a van and, you know,
they brought all their
pieces down to Cheyenne,
and including this giant elk.
So we unloaded the van,
and this piece wasn't
in it, and we asked him.
We said, "Well, how about
that piece with the arm?"
and he said, "Oh, there wasn't
room for it with all the rest
of this other stuff I was
bringing, so I didn't bring it,"
you know, so we were
like, "Phew."
[Laughter] That solved
that problem,
but it raised a lot of issues.
You know, what is
traditional taxidermy,
and what is the direction of
taxidermy, and who decides?
I mean you can do a whole
exhibit around this piece
and talk about all
of these issues.
It just wasn't something we
were expecting to deal with.
So once we got through
all of that,
this giant moving van showed
up from Minnesota just
after the Fourth of July with
all of the exhibit stuff in it,
and they had three people
on their crew there who came
with it and unloaded everything.
They had all the cases, and some
of the pieces were too big to go
in the freight elevator, like
our mule, whose name is Art.
They had to carry them
up through the museum,
and the visitors got a
big kick out of that.
So they were there for two
weeks seven days a week,
12 hours a day, doing this
installation, and Annie
and I had to be there
the whole time,
because there were all
kinds of little decisions.
Which label goes with
which fishing rod,
and where do you
want to hang the elk?
And so it was pretty
intense, and we were --
we have a Facebook page called
Art of the Hunt: Wyoming.
We haven't posted for a
while, but it's still there,
but I've been taking
photos of the installation
and posting them and trying
to get excitement
about the exhibit.
So they had brought in this
guy to hang murals for a couple
of days, and so I posted this
picture that included the mule,
and a guy who was on the board
of the state parks
immediately responded.
I don't think it
was on Facebook.
I think he wrote head of
state parks, and he said,
"That's not the kind of
packs we use in Wyoming."
I think it's called a
box pack, and he said,
"They do that in Montana.
We don't do that here.
We tie our packs with
a double diamond hitch,
and that's what should
be in this exhibit.
This is wrong."
So that word got back to
us pretty quick [laughter].
Oh. So the museum -- and we
had wanted interactive stuff
in the exhibit, so they
had tried to find a pack
where people could
practice tying the knots.
Visitors could actually
tie the knots.
So the exhibit company had
researched and found this type
of pack where you could do that,
but we didn't double-check,
which we did with most
other things, you know,
if they had sent us
this information.
We should have gone
to a packer and say,
"Is this accurate for Wyoming?"
We didn't.
So this guy said, "You
know, this is wrong.
You can't do this.
I'm going to tell all my friends
not to come to your exhibit,"
and so we had to scramble.
The museum really wanted to keep
the hands-on part, and we said,
"No, we have to -- the
people we want to come
to this exhibit are the
people who will know,
the people who are
hunters and packers,
and if they see something
wrong, they will let us know,
and we have to do it right."
So we took the packs
off, and for a while,
we thought we would just
leave the pack saddle
so people could see it, because
if it's got a pack on it,
you can't see it, but then
once the exhibit opened,
the museum found that people
were putting their kids
up here [laughter] and
taking pictures of them.
I said, "No, we cannot
have that."
So we got in touch with a packer
friend of ours, Ollie Hill,
and had him -- we had
to buy all this gear
and had him pack it properly and
tie this double diamond hitch,
which is beautiful, but it's
not something people can do.
It's too complicated.
So we lost the hands-on element,
but we have the right kind
of pack there, and we should
have -- I mean that's our fault.
We should have researched
it better.
We did it with things, like
guns, that we knew we knew --
didn't know anything about.
We would write a label and
send it to the gunsmith
and say, "Is this correct?"
You know, the caliber and the
type of stock and whatever,
because we knew people --
we hoped people who
came were going to know.
So the exhibit got finished.
Here's our entry
gate, which is --
we had been dreaming
about for years.
We had -- Carla did
the metalwork.
We commissioned the metalwork.
It looks like a typical
ranch gate.
There was an introductory
panel on what is folk art,
what is folklore to kind
of give people the idea
of how we were approaching
this material.
The first section is a fly-tying
bench and a leather workshop
and the getting prepared,
making your stuff.
Then you came around to
where you were in camp.
We had a tent company
in Sheridan make a little
short piece of tent for us.
There's the camp stove.
We had a corral with some
saddles and horse gear.
Inside the tent, we had
the firearms and knives,
and we had some bows
and arrows in the tent.
Then you came around the corner,
and there was this campfire
scene, and that dome up above,
if you walked under it, it would
trigger little audio sections.
We had about a dozen little
short stories, hunting stories.
Then you came around to the
back home, all of the taxidermy,
the decorative arts, the
quilts, the wood carving.
Here's looking the
other direction.
We had a little caf
table with a menu
with some recipes
for cooking game.
So we had an opening
reception first of August.
About a dozen of the artists
came, including Tex and Dale,
posing here with their
photograph that was made
into a directional sign.
The caterer's husband was
a hunter, so we had venison
and trout for refreshments
at the opening,
and then we had another
reception for legislators
at the beginning of the year.
They only meet early in the
year, and here's a couple
of them sitting with
the head of state parks
and cultural affairs, listening
to some of the stories,
and here's a story from
our governor, Matt Mead,
who grew up in a ranching
family near Jackson,
and he has a hunting story about
hunting with his grandfather,
who was also the governor.
Oops. Go back.
That's supposed to play.
>> I did grow up hunting,
and it's interesting,
because the family was
a big hunting family,
because my great-grandparents'
homestead is in Teton County,
and they were ranchers,
and at that time
in our state's history,
especially with ranchers,
you know, beef was
considered quite a luxury,
and in other words, you
didn't eat your own product,
and so my great-grandparents and
my grandparents and even my mom,
you know, when you
talked about meat
for them personally consuming,
it was through hunting,
and whether it was
elk, antelope, moose,
that's how they fed themselves.
They didn't go butcher
the fat steer.
They took care of
themselves through hunting,
and so from an early age,
that was instilled in me,
and the value of hunting is
it's not only great recreation,
it's not only great
for getting around
and seeing Mother Nature's
wonders, but it's really a way
to sustain yourself, and I
can't remember how old I was,
but I was young, and my first
hunt was with my grandfather,
Cliff Hansen, and it was
the day before Thanksgiving,
and we went out on
the ranch to a place
where we have a spring crick,
and so very open water,
and he had a big side-by-side
double-barrel shotgun,
and he was worried that I
couldn't stand and shoot it,
because he was worried it'd
knock me down, and so we snuck
over the crick, and
he had me sit down,
and then he sat behind
me and braced me,
and a mallard came
by, and I didn't wait
for the mallard to fly.
He wanted me to make
sure I hit the bird,
and I did hit the bird, and
then he made a big production
of us cleaning it, and then
we had it for Thanksgiving,
and as a little kid, that
was a big, big deal to me.
>> That's a great hunting
story, and the governor,
he was really excited
about this project.
I think he came to
see the exhibit.
I mean it's right across
the street from the capitol,
so we never heard
specifically, but --
and then in conjunction with
the exhibit, we did a series
of artist demonstrations
and panel discussions
that were funded by our
state humanities council.
So here's Rich Wormington with
his bows in the various stages
of production, so people
could see the process.
This guy, Ty Hallock,
we actually didn't know
about when we put
the exhibit up.
He decorates coolers and fly
tackle boxes with these drawings
of fish that he does
with Sharpies.
These are just great, and we
definitely would have had one
in the exhibit, but we didn't
know about him in time,
but we had him at one
of our demonstrations.
Karen Mott from Lander, she
raises sheep and processes it,
and then she makes
cinches for saddles.
So she has this jig
that she made up,
and she's making a
cinch out of her wool.
This is Ollie Hill,
who packed our mule.
He had this funky
horse that he made
to show how you pack an
animal for going back
into the back country,
and then we did a --
we had four panel discussions.
The first one was taxidermists
that John moderated.
We had one with guides
and outfitters.
We had one with family
traditions, and we had one
with game wardens, and game
wardens have excellent stories,
because they're always out on
adventures and chasing people,
and people are giving
them these insane stories
about how the deer got in
the back of their truck
without a tag, and [laughter]
so we had a really
great panel discussion
with these three game wardens,
and then I just love
this picture
of these little girls
talking to Kim Olsen.
It's like, "I could be a
game warden, you know."
You can just see they
just idolize her.
"I can wear a red shirt."
And these are the same kids in
the picture with the bow maker.
I realized when I was
putting this show together.
It's like, "That's
the same family."
So I assume they're a
hunting family and came
to several of our productions.
So the exhibit was up
for just over a year,
and all of the artists were
really honored were really
honored to be part
of it and thanked us,
and part of the goal was to
help people know about them
and maybe help them
in their business.
I don't know if that
actually happened,
but they were all really
pleased to be included.
So this is all that's
left of the show,
the top bar of the gate, but
you can see Carla's metalwork.
This is hanging in the Arts
Council office, so Annie gets
to look at it every
day, but we are --
Annie and I are still
so tuned into hunting.
We just became aware of how deep
and how wide its influence was
in the state, and we
keep seeing things.
We call it the project
that won't die [laughter].
There's always more to see.
I was out in Green River
last fall and walked
by this meat processing company
and had to take a picture
of their sign, and they have
that nice little
battling elk metalwork
on top of their building.
It's just a pervasive
part of Wyoming culture,
and we were just really thrilled
that we were able to get
into it, and now we can't
get out of it [laughter].
So that's my talk, and
this is another one
of Glenda's beadwork pieces.
So if anybody has any questions
or if there are any hunters
who have -- does this
ring true with you?
Bill?
>> This has been a
great exploration
of the physical stuff
with hunting.
What about their stories that
you had, and I guess traditions?
I always heard when a person
kills their first deer,
they rip their shirt
or whatever.
>> Andrea Graham: They
rip their shirt and --
>> Yeah.
>> Andrea Graham: Yeah.
Yeah, we had a lot of those
stories, stories about the one
that got away, the
stories about --
several people told us stories
about teaching their kids
to hunt, and they
taught their kids
that you don't just go wantonly
shoot things like squirrels
and birds, and if
a kid did that,
they would make them clean
the animal and eat it,
because you don't waste
food, you know, so those kind
of lessons that people
are passing on their kids,
stories about maybe -- you know,
someone might have had a chance
at this beautiful trophy buck,
but they never were in a place
to really get a good clean,
shot, the idea of a clean shot.
You don't make the
animal suffer.
We heard lots of those stories.
You know, just the lessons.
>> And have you done anything
with these stories
other than enjoyed them?
>> Andrea Graham:
[Laughter] They're
in our archive, in
our collection.
Some of those, that little
campfire scene, you know,
we had some of those shorter --
you know, the two that I played,
the governor and the guy about
the good hunt with his kid.
So we had several of
those in the exhibit as,
you know, the audio track.
>> Do the same families tend
to be both hunters and fishers,
or are they one or the other?
>> Andrea Graham: There
are a lot more fishers,
just because it's simpler
to do, less equipment.
Somehow killing a fish is not
the same as killing a deer.
You don't have to deal with --
so there are a lot
more people who fish.
I would say most hunters
probably also fish,
but not necessarily
fishers also hunt.
Hunting is a pretty
big undertaking.
>> Is catch and release
common with ice fishing?
>> Andrea Graham: Apparently.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
>> One of the things
that's common among hunters
in this area are
supernatural stories.
I don't know if you've ran
across those kinds of stories,
where the legends of
the area get bound
up with the hunter's lore.
Like, you know, a
dog, it gets excited,
and they think they're
going after game,
and hunters are running after
the dog as fast as they can,
the dog runs into a graveyard
and then sits down and howls,
-- because whatever --
>> Andrea Graham: Oh.
>> -- the dog was
chasing, it was --
>> Andrea Graham: Isn't there.
>> -- gone.
>> Andrea Graham: Yeah.
There are sort of legendary
animals that people see
for years and sort of
really don't want to kill,
because it's this majestic,
giant beast, and yeah.
So I'm sure there
are those, yeah.
>> Is that a bag?
>> Andrea Graham: Yes.
Yeah.
>> Did you deal with
buffalo hunting at all?
Are there buffalo?
Do people hunt buffalo
in [inaudible]?
>> Andrea Graham: Yeah.
They're not really wild.
I mean the ones that
roam are in Yellowstone,
and you're not allowed
to hunt in Yellowstone.
The tribes have some.
Thanks for coming.
The tribes have recently
reintroduced
and gotten their own herds, and
I think they maybe sell licenses
for a few hunts on
the reservation,
but they're generally
not out wandering around.
There's bison farms where people
raise them for their meat,
but they're not out
roaming around,
generally, like they used to be.
Okay. Oh.
>> Did you come across any
like, well, local organizations
that would put out, you know,
periodic newsletters and things
like that, or like for
community gatherings,
like or was it more individual
sort of family-based groups?
>> Andrea Graham: Some of both.
They're -- a number of
communities will have
like game dinners,
where people will bring
in their wild game prepared
in different ways, you know,
and you have a tasting, so
you could try, you know,
venison enchiladas or
[laughter] -- so there is that.
Of course, there are, you know,
loads of local organizations
and state organizations.
There's hunters or Sportsmen
for Public Lands that want
to preserve public lands.
This idea of federal lands
being given to the state --
they do not like that,
because they want those open
public spaces.
That's where you can hunt.
>> I think that --
>> Andrea Graham: Okay.
>> Well, Andrea, thank you
so much for coming [applause]
and for being so [inaudible].
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.